how's it going rest my neighbor ah and
welcome to dread out demo I heard about
this game first time a long time ago
it's an Indonesian horror game and the
demo was released I think yesterday had
the old set up you helped you [ __ ]
happy
well I be playing it Indonesian or
English my Indonesian is not that good
so I guess I'll go with starting your
game I got to enter my name ah one more
laughter nipple liqueur of justic ice to
it
from what I've seen it looks like they
are taking a lot of inspiration from
failed frame which is really lucky I'll
just shut up because there's sexy time
oh hello Linda me Linda are you doing
well Melinda the Linda what and the
heavens are you doing sleeping in a
chair I can't see [ __ ] I'm like ah
Melinda Belinda answered the phone so
yeah it's the third person horror it it
looks really nice to be like a what is
it coming from
hello hey yes this is peds oh it's it's
era hey I was I'm sleep
can I get a second she's dying to meet
me no oh [ __ ] dad is creepy man I mean I
know I'm beautiful but not that
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna use the phone we're
gonna use the phone at it awesome this
is I cry of pills except oh oh melon
Belinda Belinda what are we doing okay
it's fine Melinda Belinda we can do this
you have tits what the [ __ ] alright well
like we're going this way press ah hi
maybe maybe she's not that bad
hi hi how shed what the hell is going on
oh it's dark now lights on please
oh [ __ ] I just realized I forgot to turn
on my heartbeat sensor Oh No
okay it's okay Bruce don't worry I know
exactly what I'm doing
and by that I mean I I'm pretty sure I'm
surprised I'm alive who is that girl
what is that number okay we're going
here bro muchachos
Oh swings I love swings how you doing
there whoa whoa no no no no no nein nein
bitter shot not out of 4500 sure that is
done diddly creepy I don't know I wanna
put the fire by the but the baby the but
about the but save us okay okay oh I
must not on my Instagram you [ __ ] well
I oh you like that you don't want to be
only in social media huh uh-oh I find
your weakness Oh shade that is done
diddly creepy man I am out of here
[ __ ] this game [ __ ] everyone what what
plants you're scaring me again I don't
know hi hi I who wants to be on Facebook
who wants to have a new proper picture
ah anyone and no Twitter profile No
hashtag beautiful I will Photoshop you
beautiful don't worry about it I won't
upload anything you don't like not Amy
man that ain't me Whiteside [ __ ] voice
out ugly [ __ ] okay so I do not cheat
but as you can say there's a hole in the
wall hair through the camera I'm a tech
picture via Facebook and then I'm a I'm
a I'm a blog about it
okay okay I got it I got it I got it
cheese no that won't work either
oh so I go through with the camera that
doesn't make any sense what the hell is
this
iris phone hey I always wanted to have
an iris phone iPhone Persis I was dying
Masuka love that guy it's like being
drunk in indonesian i think you job lot
about family
quit night what the [ __ ] was that oh
it's just a bug yeah yeah it flies
through the waves
I mean walls we're going hey [ __ ] that
guy who live in there by going in my
stuff oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't want to go
in their bras gonna be completely
oh yeah blah what what oh oh [ __ ] it
froze for a second okay breasts look
fine
this is just a game games can hurt me I
am fine
we're all fine look it's pretty light in
here actually like this play don't mind
is it Oh nope why would I mind us I mean
I got bugs see with me hi how you doin
thanks for coming with me hey yeah hey
get off [ __ ] oh why why is it heartbeat
why is it heart beating why stop bug
you're bugging me stop
you're [ __ ] bug I will slap the dick
out of you whoa well what in heaven's
Teddy who did this to you Teddy bog was
it you
bog you're pissing me off man you're
pissing me I'm outta here
Oh job la reponse carpets Victor okay
that's okay
Hey hi hi hi hey hey hi I'm sorry bog
god damn you're like the new [ __ ]
barrel Teddy what happened are you
why would I am sick of this [ __ ] I'm
item here hi how are you you look like
you need a hug come here okay you know
what ah
how you doing that sir
you what are you doing I'm dancing in
front of a bug what does it look like
how do I get who are you you're not my
friend
I don't know but we have to get out of
here Oh oh good
some lesbo action love it it's [ __ ]
bog
well you please stop what you gonna do
now and what you could have told me
about the bug man a girl it's that guy
it's like I'll let this one slide one
more and I [ __ ] kill you okay now I'm
just kidding I would never hurt you you
are too beautiful I could never hurt
that beautiful face I don't I don't cry
hi hi I'm so I was just a joke I will
still please please stop crying let's
find out what happened to beer I'll call
you Betsy if that's okay beer beer Betsy
who did this
was it the fly huh Betsy you can talk to
me where did he touch you
was it here Betsy Betsy I'm your friend
don't be afraid Betsy no how does he
even stand on that chair look Betsy
Betsy you're funny I like you man oh
there's stairs wonderful Betsy Betsy
where are you oh hey Betsy um oh you
want an ass sure you want an ass shot
huh okay uh that fine uh I'll just I
guess I'll just email them to you uh
shoes I love your shoes where did you
get them but hey Betsy Betsy Betsy why
don't you talk to me Oh
oh gosh ah
Betsy now I understand why you know show
your face in the picture what was I
supposed to die there I think I was
because I clicked I clicked a snap it
yeah I I I [ __ ] that it it doesn't
want I do it on you bros i cleanse you
someone behind it enough skin stupid I'm
sorry I'm sorry you're crying because I
was so but it was
now you're just exaggerating bros run to
the light they said well why not
so I guess I'm dead that's nice that's a
good way to go that's a good way to go
oh no I thought it was over
Betsy I am sick of your [ __ ] man girl
sorry whatever you are I don't know I
thought I saw some beard on her face I
wanna lay who's crying who's crying
a mattress a crying mattress pathetic
is it is it downstairs I think it's
coming from downstairs poor ChaCha's Oh
madness up okay hey how's it going girl
oh I'm sorry about the picture not
coming out out great I can't leave this
place you're the only one who can get
out of this place you have to get out of
here take this key and leave now now you
have the key to the main door
cool I didn't even know there was a main
door hi a final picture cheese salty
[ __ ] uh-huh all right um ah what the
[ __ ] I'm taking pictures everywhere so
far what the [ __ ] did you do oh it's
just a thunder
I'm not scared enough Thunder okay okay
okay
I'm good I'm good uh oh it's just a
graveyard haha okay nothing wrong with a
brave yard I mean dead people are at
graveyards that people are cool I
thought hang out with them all the time
it's normal
don't look at me like that where the
[ __ ] am I
why the [ __ ] are we going it's so [ __ ]
narc Oh candles thank heavens
hey candles how are you even lit can I
take you up oh there's a clue here okay
okay
something about the candles huh gotcha I
got you oh yeah there was a candle Oh JA
bloody hell with them authoritative
blood what the bug Facebook picture
favorite picture Twitter picture proper
picture I [ __ ] post your nipple your
mama will know about this picture okay
I'm sorry
I'm sorry I won't upload anything bet
you can't tell you can't control the
system what does it want
it's so mean how did us what okay I'll
take a picture of you yes and then I'll
go to the other ones now I'm at a party
- do we add yeah picture picture picture
picture picture bacon ribbit ribbit so
many [ __ ] pictures you have no idea I
got so many hot pictures oh my god
fabulous this is going on some
Victoria's Secrets oh my [ __ ] god
you're so popular right there two of you
now that ain't fair man why is there two
candles lit now that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
is that guy still after me I don't get
it Oh
Oh how does that feel not so good I
would assume ha ha yeah yeah all right
I'm kicking ass man there better [ __ ]
be three candles now but I'm gonna shove
my candle up my ass oh oh good thing I
don't have to do that [ __ ] all right so
I did it we did it for us somehow I
don't know how I tell you how what what
changed nothing changed I got all the
candles what else do you want do I need
to take a picture of all of you Oh
oh hi hi you don't when I was dancing
excuse me sir that is rude whoa whoa hey
nice necklace girl what are they doing
now she had a dream about going to the
place that is a good demo I like that
nice duck face
don't go there
thread out cool cool sounds fun I
enjoyed that anyway I hope you enjoyed I
hope you [ __ ] happy about the new
them their camera being back or whatever
your [ __ ] welcome I'm not pissed no
way is less work for me anyway